okay uh
settle down okay yeah so the last stop
ran a little
long so uh i'm i'm not going to make it
in the time slot
from the uh as stated on the schedule
uh probably pushing pushing it forward
later okay so
um uh good talk be talking about some
things about the s frame and the s graph
and kind of like uh what what a little
kind of what we do at dato
and why user care i guess so what is
data
so uh if you have heard of graph lab we
work on graph lab
we change the name to data sometime in
the top i think it's getting cut off
on this side
that's there again
better
come back
okay anyway so uh it was finally
on somewhere around mid-2013 by
professor carlos question we
changed the name to dato sometimes uh
early this year
last year because when we call it graph
lab everyone thinks we have a graph
database
we are not a graph database uh we do a
lot more
right and so who am i so i was a student
of carlos so
as one of the co-founders together plus
a few of his our students of the
students we started
we started data i did my thesis work
with on
distributed machine learning uh as at
one point we
built this kind of power graph that's
kind of the core bit of my thesis
which is you know essentially it was
faster this should be growth processing
framework
though uh it's more like hpc style of uh
distributed processing
so now i'm the co-founder and one the
chief architect at dato
okay so what is it we do i will not
um go too much into the
more pitchy stuff but essentially the
basic idea is
to make it easy for people to go from
all the way from
data engineering to uh making machine
learning models
iterating on that and taking into
production is to
uh because essentially we begin uh uh
where
we're large group we have a large
machine learning people of
we play with a lot of data we take in a
lot of customers send us data we have
seen data of all types of a lot a lot of
different types
and what we do is we try to make it
really easy
for us to manipulate and do stuff with
those data and therefore make it really
easy for everyone else
to manipulate and do useful stuff with
the data okay
so let's take a quick a really quick
demo
okay so what we are is a python library
with
a c plus backend okay uh
and you begin essentially import graph
lab
sgl now so we're gonna take a
if you guys came to my tutorial this is
kind of a very very condensed fragment
of it
uh so this is the yelp review data set
okay so each row of this abbreviated
essentially json string okay now one way
we can think about
uh such a file is that it's actually a
csv file
it's a csv file with each row is a
dictionary
each each row contains exactly one
dictionary and that's all it is
right so we call read csv on it
with no header
we read the first hundred lines so with
the new juvederm i think our incremental
printing broke a bit but we correctly
infer
that the column type is one dictionary
we parse it
and we get a table okay so we have
some more most interesting type
influences parsing capabilities
right and uh each row is essentially
exactly one dictionary you can
arbitrarily slice and dice
uh like an array now except that the
srim
actually goes out uh actually scales out
way beyond memory
okay so we have insurance capabilities
to unpack
columns i'm paying for for for instance
essentially x1 is just this big
dictionary right
so we can unpack the column and we end
up
with a table of business id
date review id stars and so on
okay we can see the votes here
which there we go scrolling is slightly
awkward
but votes here is still packed and still
a dictionary funny useful and cool
we can further unpack that we can unpack
on votes
again and then now we
pull out just the vote uh
we pull out the uh we expand out the
votes column right so we're very nice
very easy
uh uncharted data processing
capabilities now something
we can do quickly just to much better
than just
displaying an ipython notebook is uh our
show function which very quickly gets a
summary of every column of the data
right so all these summaries uh this
summary
views are done by uh using very fast one
pass
uh sketching sketching procedures so for
we can get an estimation of the number
of unique items
we get as the uh approximate accounts of
all the frequent items
and the number of stuff we can get we
can get approximate quantiles for
we can get quantiles on everything uh
yep so for instance date
very quickly we see the most frequent
item is january 3rd which is
conveniently my birthday
yep so and also very nice as a table
view
which rather zoom out to just give you a
sense of it
you can look at all the data very
quickly this
is essentially excel is a very powerful
tool excel is very very useful it just
gives you a very quick overview of your
data
this view scales uh regard regardless of
how big your stream is
how big your data is we page in things
as you scroll along
okay so
going back to here streams are column
wise mutable
so you can modify and add or remove
columns easily you can do
numeric abrasives on columns and each
column is really as an s array so we can
quickly create a column called total
votes and
we have very powerful filtering
capabilities so few total votes greater
than zero
this essentially gives returns me an s
every type is integer but it's a binary
ones and zeros
for each row whether the number of total
force is greater than zero
and then we can do this which is what i
call logical filter so reviews
select all reviews where the number of
total votes is greater than zero
okay so this is the first hint that
the stream is doing something
interesting at the back end we do not
know the number of rows in this stream
so in the back end a bunch of query
query optimization
is being performed so say if we want to
do some classification funny
right whether review is funny or not uh
okay so
let's say that reviews are at least one
vote for funding is funny right
and this will just binarize
the funny column we sub select out just
the text and funny so we are just going
to look at text
the text column and
we can do account words so we'll just do
a really a sparse
sparse model just a parameter for each
word
that okay so that just takes each column
and turns
it into uh the text column and
dictionary right
so you see a lot of things that i'll run
instantly there's
kind of the lazy evaluation capability
go in the background which i'll talk
about
so uh now i'm going to quickly build a
logistic regression classifier on
reviews
categorizing on funny it will take all
the remaining columns which i guess is
just text
and it will try to do something same
with it you'll automatically take a
dictionary column in the response
feature if
you have a string columns you
automatically integrate past feature it
is a little longer largely because of
this evaluation going on it has to
evaluate everything above and also
incremental
printing is broken which we will have to
fix it will take
approximately 20 seconds
so it automatically pick the pixel
solver for you
we have about three servers in back end
and we end up with a model
which we can then use and take the
production
using some of our remaining capabilities
which i will not demonstrate here
so that's it that's a quick
demo okay
so first
yes we run on a single machine this is
right now all running from my laptop
and we uh and when you have a bit yeah
and everything is being done on one
machine
so here's the question what can you do
on a single machine
how much can you do a single machine
right and uh this is what we can do on a
single machine
it'll be a collaborative filtering model
matrix factorization on about 20 billion
user item ratings
we can perform page rank 128 billion
each graph
right and on a single machine how
and this is kind of the two core data
structures we have which is the s frame
and the s graph
so the
s frame uh behaves a lot like uh it's
essentially we have a pandas data frame
uh it's easy to make a make s frames you
construct it
from uh so from here i'm just
constrained from dictionary
with one column x and five values uh we
can do
modification arbitrary modification
columns so it's not quite
uh it's not quite like a database table
right you can perform
a degree of mutation on it it's column
wise immutable though
so we can apply arbitrary python lambda
operations
we can create new columns very easily
using vectorized operators
and we can very easily subset like
columns
right and the design principles we go in
the back end is
to have a kind of graceful degradation
which is
we have an objective which is we try to
always work
regardless how much memory you have we
try to always work
we have very rich data types as we see
we have a list with a built-in
lit recursive list type recognitive
dictionary types which these those can
recurse arbitrarily and with very
powerful operators to unpack
pack them stack them in different ways
we also have an
image type which is very useful we pack
an entire image into one cell so each
row
is one image and the back end is a
columnar architecture to support very
easy feature engineering addition and
removal columns and so forth
and the key is really is like columns
are first class citizens we have a type
called an s array
uh so the s frame really behaves a lot
more like an arbitrary collection of
columns
than a database table
so the internal representation of the s
frame
is actually it's not turns out not very
complicated so say we are creating uh we
load stream from disk right so when
loading x from this because the the back
end of the sram is actually is based on
a disk based storage we cache a lot in
memory but
it's based on this based array so
opening an arbitrary large s frame just
revolves as pointing to the file we do
not actually need to load anything
so what that does is we create an s
frame three columns
and those just point to their
corresponding locations on disk
say we load a different s frame right so
maybe someone else has a normalized
rating field for instance right
and that just creates a new s frame
which points with the
same three columns pointing different
locations on disk
we create new call uh we create we add a
column to our first
sram called maybe a normalized rating
and all that does
is create a new column and points it to
the
uh to the the column in the other file
we compare difference between the rating
field between the rating fields of these
two columns that creates a new anonymous
column
right coming up which is generated by
computing the the difference between the
rating field and one and the rating
field and the other
and well there's a there's a we call it
diff this is an s
array and this is our equivalent of an
external memory numpy
array and if we create uh
add this column to our s frame assigning
the name div
that just creates a new entry in the or
in our sram sf called div which points
to our new
anonymous sla
the internal physical representation is
a it's a column store uh a user
so for instance i have three columns
user movie and rating as a column store
kind of arbitrary
misaligned blocks uh essentially this
allows us to get
the maximum amount of compression
regardless of how
large for the maximum compression for
each column regardless of
how large the data is so because if we
stick an entire image
in the cell for instance right uh then
if uh there's only that much and you
have very sparse
uh small numeric values everywhere else
you don't want
to align your align the table against
that very big image value right so this
will also compress user movie and
ratings
in every column using the best
compression
process possible for each one right and
all these are packed together
into a single file or potentially
multiple files
uh in arbitrary order and we have a
series of compression algorithms going
on in the back end
to make it uh to make it go fast
so then how do we
perform evaluation on this thing right
how
where are all these math operators how
do we like do projects and joints and so
on
so this is where kind of the idea of
lazy evaluation comes in
so lazy valentine's and lazy valuation
is very common so spark has it
uh blaze does that to some uh and
it's uh it essentially lets us pipe line
operators and this is especially
important
if we are going to external memory going
to disk into ssd
because this avoids us writing out to
disk all the time
right and um but because our columns are
first class citizens this requires us to
extend
somewhat from classical sequel
optimization procedures
because we need to maintain both tables
and columns and the pro
the mechanism of doing so we can do give
a quick
example here so this uh we learned an s
frame
from some source we're going to project
out the ratings column
so uh the rating is an s array and what
that does is just
creates a new node in the in the graph
we multiply by two
creates a new node in the graph and
rating some point to the new node
we assign it back to uh to the
to the original s frame so that's uh
there's a there's a
we call it union columns but essentially
we're taking columns from two different
places and
uh combining them together
and we do a sum on that right so once
again we project out the ratings column
and then we perform a reduction
on that right so now next is kind of the
idea of query optimization
given this graph how do we best perform
the reduction operation
first is that we can say a project can
be fused into union
we do not need to union to project one
column we can
we can pass the project through the
union and because we can read a single s
array directly
we can combine the projection into the
source itself
right and so this is the actual physical
plan that's being executed
when you perform that sum so we take the
original source we multiply it by two
and perform reduction on it
so the idea of query optimization gives
you this very very rich
source of performance optimizations uh
pushing filter operations upwards
pushing project operation upwards
pushing complex
joint operations downwards downwards not
downloads
joint ordering and so on we have we have
only a few implemented
now in uh graph library 1.4
which is hopefully coming in about a
week or so uh
in the last month or so we completely
re-architected the
back-end execution engine of the s-frame
uh so you actually see
uh some good performance gains
with with the new 1.4 engine and it
gives us room to start
putting together throwing together all
these query optimization tricks
so um so here is a really
cute example left side is a
left side is one it's it's kind of like
a fast testing thing
left side is uh it's a randomly
generated plan
uh the right side is the actual
optimized plan and this is just kind of
one of the
acute examples of query optimization uh
being performed
in this case we are kind of fast testing
our optimizer we
generate a random plan we
execute it we optimize it execute it
again
we see whether we get exactly the same
answers at the end
okay but even the performing execution
requires uh requires a lot of carrying
comes optimization especially
when you are performing a lot of
compression right because
you come at the risk that uh
when you uncompress the data it will no
longer fit in memory
right because for instance our block
sizes are something like 64 kilobytes
we pass through two phases of uh just
regular uh kind of like irregular
integer encoding followed by lz4
encoding
so what have if your numbers are all
zeros and ones
and you is an integer column right
now uh first all that just gets packed
into one bit per value
and then after that lc4 may take it even
smaller
target 64 kilobytes compressed right so
when uncompressed
that single cell can become a million a
single
origin 64-bit can become a million
integers can become a
10 million integers so you have to be
very careful when performing
when performing decompression so we have
a lot of optimizations in the back end
so we have a co-routine based
incremental decoder so we
uh decline the flight we do not ever
need to maintain all the decompressed
information in memory
at any one point we only need to hold
compressed
state in memory uh runtime input
skipping and so on and so forth
right and the outcome is that
just looking at filter performance and
as it turns out also grouped by
performance but i don't have the
benchmarks here
we can outperform many other things on a
single machine so
this is a simple filter operation where
selecting
is fully synthetic data really this is
some on the
smart benchmarks page where we ran
just select pages where some patreon
values grade 100
we can run it faster on a single machine
than anything else on five machines
or even when the selection output is
bigger
and how large does this scale we cache
significantly memory we go out to disk
the largest synthetic set we have
performed has
950 columns and one billion rows dense
numeric
about one trillion numeric values and
all that is on a single machine and we
can do useful things on it there's no
real
limit on the number of rows but there's
uh practically
uh usefully about 100 to thousands of
columns there's limitations
of most columnar uh columnar
representations and something we are
optimizing
though that said we had a customer push
us use us on about
a hundred thousand columns and i'm
surprised it works but it does work
yeah but uh you said oh as the number of
columns start to increase to tens of
thousands
your wide beats become slower and that's
kind of a necessary effect of most
columnar compressed
columnar databases
so how do we get graphs from this
so this is the uh so we have been known
for graphs our original research group
was known for growth very big
distributed graphs we also had this
project called graphqi
which is look which looked at external
memory graphs doing computational
external graphs
and so we want graphs and
people find grouse useful people have
social networks uh you have user item
graphs and things like that
right so our s graph uh
is our counterpart to the s frame
to s frame table but handles graphs and
internally is built entirely using s
frames so we
shard the vertices essentially really we
randomly partition the vertices
uh into a collection of shards you can
set the number of shards
and each shard is an s frame so you can
have arbitrary attributes on vertices
essentially you can go as graph dot
vertices and you get an s
frame which you can then join and do
arbitrary operations with any other with
any other table
the edges however are partitioned into
p squared partitions
p p squared s frames right where
say partition 2 four contains only edges
connecting vertices in partition two
and vertices in partition four and
because they're s frames as well
you can now saw arbitrary uh is still a
table you can store arbitrary attributes
you go s graph dot edges you really get
s
frame back and you can do whatever you
want with it right
so and to perform computation
so this also lets us do extensive
compression because
we need less bits to represent we need
less bits to represent
uh source ids and destination ids and so
on so compression turns out to be
much improved so the age so to perform
computation
if uh efficiently without uh
extensive paging uh we
walk the graph essentially in the
hilbert curve ordering
so we sweep through the edges in the
huber cup ordering and this gives us a
good performance
gains when x when accessing vertex data
right and really all you need for a lot
of graph computation operations is the
ability to sweep
through edges very quickly as fast as
you can
right and uh the outcome is that on a
single machine we can open from 16
machines
and this is on the twitter graph uh
pagerank
and connected components we
significantly outperform
16 machines and this is because
there is a really nice connected
components algorithm
that is really really really hard to
distribute
union find the union find algorithm
uh can get you all the connect
components in one pass
but then that algorithm is extremely
non-trivial to distribute
and so for all for all the other
distributed
graph procedures they can do by
propagation they require
a number of essentially
diameter up to diameter number of number
of iterations to converge
whereas we can actually complete it in
one part efficiently
in shared memory with one machine so
scalability of this thing so uh
this is uh this is something new for in
1.4
which once again will come out in one
week we
managed to run this on the largest
public
graph you can find a common curl graph
with three and a half billion
vertices and 128 billion edges
represented naively on the single
machine requires at least
two requests at least two terabytes of
memory right
kind of a two into just two integers per
inch with some care you can get less
but then you you pay in different ways
right and we run this
on one machine one ssd page rank at nine
minutes per iteration we run full
contact components
in about an hour
so
we have these two core underlying data
structures s frame and s graph
but our key object so uh these
these two their structures sms graph
will be open source
uh they are technically open source but
again
it's not exactly a python package right
now but uh
you uh you will soon i'm trying to
uh factor out refactor the coin in a way
so that we can compile these into
a separate uh python package these two
pieces
will be open source and you'll be able
to use them anywhere um
button so the key however is everything
else
in the pipeline as well how do you get
machine learning how to get deployment
we'll not be talking about deployment
rajat talked about defined extensively
yesterday
but machine learning then right
so all our machine learning algorithms
use s-frame
as the back-end data source
but the model the model is atmosphere in
memory by the implementations itself in
c plus plus and use
whatever it takes to go fast essentially
parallel execution
control memory access races this is
algorithms that wrote some some machine
immigrants are actually robust to this
if you are careful there are proofs
about that
uh multiple solvers for different
regimes gpus
uh yeah and one of the key is that
robustness and ease of use is a key
objective
not just performance the idea
we solve effect we work effectively with
both sparse and dance regimes we have
multiple servers optimizations
for both sparks and dancer gyms and we
probably have the most one of the most
robust linear servers out there
that work across all regimes if
effectively whether you have
uh whether you have a ill condition it
will consume columns and so on
we detect it and we try to correct for
it
and um our vp of engineering
said garbage in guidance out this is
kind of the objective
for the machine algorithms this is a
really tall order
for many machine learning for many
machine algorithms it's not
something which uh research uh research
has done very well at the
garbage and guys out but uh and there's
that amount of diagnosis we can do on
the data
within reasonable time but this is
something we do try hard to achieve
and we have a large collection of
machine learning models
linear models trees we have a really
really good question recommended
algorithms
de-learning with gpus gp capabilities
clustering text models and so on
right you should go to the webpage and
look at the list
and the performance is quite
good we can we outperform about five
nodes
uh uh five nodes in ml lib and uh
and we did i don't have the numbers here
we have a chart elsewhere
but uh we pretty much get better results
than a higher accuracy than ml lib on
all data sets
right uh there's a question that's
that's the question of robustness which
is something that we take a lot of care
to ensure uh and uh
so we can get largest regression on the
common 100 gigabyte it says on commodity
hardware in about one half hours
on one single machine and similarly
collaborative filtering models about
four billion use item ratings
by an hour and the scale is about 20
billion so
essentially here's the question so it's
time to rethink the idea of big data
how big is big data right so
how much can we do effectively on a
single machine
and the single machine is much cheaper
easier to maintain
and much faster get working right and
it can scale to much much bigger data
sets
than you think with the appropriate
thought going into
data structure design and so on
right so this is the last bit
so distributed why distribute this
should be something where look
we do look into we are looking into and
there are
good reasons to distribute so seven you
have i o bound tasks with
when the growing distribution you get n
times the number of this network memory
bandwidth
or your compute bound embarrassing
parallel tasks
and so these are things we're working on
uh s frames a great distribute
is essentially very similar to a
database like a database like
a distributed oled database like ideas
and we're working on it graphs much
harder to distribute
but i have done it many times now kind
of i spent four or five years of my phd
time working on digital machine learning
and i do not recommend
wasting wasting time on this but the uh
but still uh
we we have we have worked on world alone
graphs and this is something that
we have very very good ideas on how to
do well but visual machine learning
so there's been many claims of digital
machine learning
but here is
a common performance file fallacy so say
i come up with a distributed algorithm
for machine learning model x
pick your x be neural networks or be
collaborate filtering
or something else and we get this
speedups
so one machine we see a thousand
examples per second on 60 machine we can
go through 15 000 examples per second
64 we can go through 62 000 examples per
second okay
that's relatively linear speed up
so have we solved the digital machine
learning problem for model
x
so here are the same thing things kind
of put together
in comparison we have two algorithms
algorithm a
we runs on a single machine we get very
high conversions rates we only require
10 passes through our data
with algorithm b it's easier to
distribute
it has low convergence rates requires
100 passes through our data but each
pass is very fast
so which is faster it kind of depends a
lot on system network characteristics
if we have less than some x number of
machines a is faster
otherwise b is faster for unknown x
the key to looking at distributed speed
ups is we should be comparing
convergence rates not throughput
convergence rates against the best known
single machine algorithm
right and uh here's a good example
so this is a chart from
a recent paper from google
uh looking at distributed deep learning
okay
uh so this is from kota with jeff then
so we can be sure the system is really
really solid this is where looking at
convergence rate time to 16
accuracy now if you look at this
carefully
uh the dot on the left is gpu
time the dot at the bottom there is
their sgd time yeah it runs
much faster but it took 600 machines to
decrease training 10 by three times
right so distributive learning is kind
of something we can tell you know
there's still some ways to go
right when the single machine
essentially if i were to just pay a
little bit longer three times a run time
i can get uh i can get pretty much as
good
i not many people have 600 machines
lying around
right so um so but so distribute ml
interesting machine learning is
notoriously hard to distribute
effectively there are some special cases
people have worked on
include kind of like uh some so there
are some thoughts we're kind of going
beyond
map reduce to think a bit more of your
hpc style and to distribute only when it
makes sense
balancing convergence rates and
throughput and this is something we are
working on
thank you
you